joining us now man entering his third
NFL season just a couple of years
removed from being the second overall
pick in the draft Bears quarterback
Mitch true Biscay Mitch how are you
buddy I'm doing good how you guys doing
thanks for having me on this morning
we're doing great great to have you and
Mitch you're here on behalf of gone
rogue snacks a product that combines the
crunchiness of a potato chip with the
protein rich benefits of jerky and has
17 plus grams of protein in each pack so
like last weekend are you sitting around
with your gone rogue snacks watching the
drafts watching every pick that all the
teams make or do or do you not pay
attention to it a couple of picks but
you've got all the facts right there you
just read them all off yeah very excited
to be a part of the launch with gone
rogue a new snack it's very healthy high
in protein and it's it's that it's it's
like a dream when it comes to snack
because it's like a chip except it's
healthy for you so I'm very excited to
be with them and yeah I watch the dress
a little bit and very excited how our
bears did and I have to think we we did
really well and where it really excited
headed into this year Mitch I want to
apologize for Mike he doesn't do any
research it's actually Pro Bowl
quarterback Mitch Travis key daniel
Jones drafted sixth overall everyone
criticizes criticizes the Giants they
criticized Daniel Jones you were drafted
to overall the bears traded up there was
maybe a little bit of unrest in the fan
base like what's going on what's it like
to be drafted and have maybe people
doubting you from day one and now
wondering if you're worth the draft pick
yeah definitely I definitely feel with
Daniel and how he feels gone to a
situation because it kind of was very
similar how it was in Chicago they could
feel uncomfortable at first because I
mean for for us we're just kids coming
out of college and it's a dream come
true you finally get picked and whoever
picks you you don't know if you're gonna
go first you don't know if you're gonna
last for us to get picked as a dream
come true and then all of a sudden you
feel like you're not accepted into this
organization or you already have this
added pressure because where you got
selected and and that that's not really
fair to the kid but at the same time
they
it's you learned that that's what comes
with the profession of playing
professional football at this level just
having to handle the fan bases handle
having to handle the the the situation
and pressure of the position you're in
now and it's just all part of the
learning process so I think at the same
time it puts a chip on your shoulder I
know it did for me everybody who doubted
me and thought I didn't deserve to be
picked number two overall I think I'm
still trying to prove those people wrong
to this day and that's something Daniel
is gonna have to do but at the same time
we're living the dream it's a dream come
true we're very blessed to be in the
situation and it really doesn't matter
if you get picked first second or get
picked in the sixth or seventh round
it's it's an amazing opportunity to play
at this level and all it all comes down
to what you make out of this opportunity
now so that's what what I've been trying
to do but you know if he calls you up
and he says you know Mitch they set
aside the whole UNC Duke thing how help
me out here give me something specific
give me something that I can do to get
through these early stages of all this
criticism all this pressure how am I
supposed to turn this into a positive
yeah definitely number one I would say
you got to block out everybody on the
outside you got to block out the media
Twitter everybody who's hating on your
situation and and trying to say that you
don't deserve it and then when you get
to the facility it's all about football
and I kind of know Daniel because I have
a good friend that coaches that Duke and
this this kids all about ball and that's
how I was - you just go in you're very
fortunate for the situation you just
can't wait to go and learn compete and
get there with the coaches and right
away you just got to get in with your
teammates and earn their respect
absolutely work your tail off and just
show that you're willing to do whatever
it takes to help the organization win
turn it around and really get things
going so I kind of know Daniel a little
bit I think he's he's up for the
challenge as was I and a lot of these
kids we just we just get picked and it's
a dream come true so you're gonna go in
there work your tail off and earn the
respect your teammates and once you
start winning games
and then then that's when you turn the
fan base but its first thing first you
gotta get in there and the respect of
your peers and then that ultimately
comes down to your teammates and your
coaches bears twitter last month called
Matt Nagy the swaggiest coach in the NFL
do you agree that would be a fact
hundred percent he is this way I guess
judging manifold did you see any reads
Hawaiian shirt at the coaches picture
day and you're still gonna stick with
that ooh oh I'm gonna stick with that
coach Coach read that he's got to be up
there probably top five Hawaiian shirt
that's a very strong move
but coach Negi I'm sure he's got a
closet full of Hawaiian shirts and that
was he he could pull it out he's it's
unbelievable
it's how different is it for you this
year that you're not having to learn a
new coaching staff a new offensive
system new everything that they're after
your first season it's so nice it's
amazing it's like we're already so much
further than we were last year at this
time having the same offense going
through year two we really it feels like
you could just really get on top of this
offense master it and just go through
all the details so we we know what we're
good at we know what we want to work at
and we're just way more focused on what
we want this offense to be how can we
can prove how we can be more explosive
convert more third downs score more
points and everything like that so just
it's made this transition going into
year three so much easier going into
year two of this offense just knowing
everyone who we have on playmaker wise
knowing your teammates all across the
board we didn't add a bunch of new guys
besides the rookies we just drafted so
we'll get that man and and we just have
great chemistry between the players on
offense and our coaches and what we're
trying to do scheme wise and we're just
so much further from where we're at so
I'm very excited to wear this offense
can be this year all right so phenomenal
year last year we all know how it ended
we don't have to go back through there I
will mention that week 17 the Vikings
rolled over I still can't believe that
but it ended poorly the Bears are
bringing in
eight kickers to try out we threw out
the idea today how far of a field goal
what's your longest field goal and do
you think you could kick a field goal in
the NFL in the game if you need to be
not saying you're gonna be say there's
an injury yeah yeah I heard I might get
thrown into the competition as well so I
kind of been working on my leg just in
case and you never know if it came down
to it I think I can make a 35 40 yarder
with the window I'm not gonna lie to you
I need the wind I need that strong
Chicago wind right at my back and I
think I got 35 in me maybe 40 if I get a
good little win behind me
old-school straight on straight on you
know in the old days that that would be
the biggest decision he'd probably be
spur the moment I used to toe kick
because youthful fall we would be the
only team the kick field goals and I'll
kick the field goals and then you start
to learn a soccer style to get more
power but if it came down to it I might
have to toe toe punch it you know get it
up there and see if we could get it
through you know one of the things that
the media types do before a game they're
always watching the kicker what's his
range how far is he making it does the
wind affect him do you pay any attention
to what your kicker looks like before a
game just so you know you know that
third and four from the 30 it's gonna be
more important than otherwise would be
because I'll have a whole lot of faith
in my guy today I actually I actually
don't I never paid attention to that
it's a couple times it's not our kicker
I pay attention to it's the other guy
because the the opposing teams kicker is
usually in our way when we're trying to
throw and we're like all right is this
guy done kicking yet we're trying to get
our warm-up in I'm trying to throw
routes and we're kept we're trying to go
around um and you try to be courteous or
whatever and not getting each other's
way because everyone's just got to get
to warm up in but I was you just
standing behind the opposing teams
kicker and you're like when's this guy
can move hey Vic Fangio is gone now he's
the defense coordinator last year did a
great job for the team whatwhat's that
transition going to be like I know
that's not your side of the ball but
it's gonna be seeing a lot of that side
of the ball in practice
yeah for sure we got a super talented
defense and
I know they're excited for Coach Pagano
and his scheme and every and in the
coaching staff he's brought in the
defensive side and they just been diving
in and we got just a veteran veteran
group on a sunbath side of the ball
they're very savvy - like you so they're
just embracing the grind of what is
offseason OTAs and picking up this new
new defense and I can't wait to go
against them soon in practice we're
gonna get it going and we're just super
talented so when they put their mind to
something and just learn this new scheme
and attack and hopefully they're gonna
be just as dominant as they were last
year last year nobody really expected
anything from the Bears and you guys
overachieved and surprised a lot of
people what's the difference this year
the mindset because there is that burden
there's that expectation that you're
gonna win the division again does it
change the way you think about things
this time of year
a little bit I think all those
expectations that we overachieved were
external we knew what we had in the
locker room and we knew how many games
we could win and we felt like every week
we're in it and then we just we felt
like we should have won more games than
we did last year so all those
expectations that we overachieved where
external last year and the the pressure
that's out from outside forces a while
as well so we're just going to control
control do go one game in as a week and
whether people believes in us they think
we should hit this number of wins or
what they didn't last year so we know
what we're capable of we know what we
have in the locker room we're very
confident group and we're excited for
this year and the the the bar is
definitely set higher so we know that
and it's not from who's setting that
expectation on the outside we're setting
that standard for itself and we're gonna
go chase it and get after it so we're
very pumped all right Mitch hey we
appreciate your time we'll check out the
gone rogue snacks available at
supermarkets and convenience stores
nationwide also at amazon.com for more
information people go to gone rogue
snacks calm all the best Mitch look
forward to talking to you again soon
appreciate thank you yes
get you some gone rogue chips
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports